So what we'll do is we'll create a new material just as a little trial just to get
us used to creating content inside of Unreal Engine.
We'll create a shiny material that has a dynamic instance to it and show you how to
apply that to a mesh inside of Unreal Engine.
So let's jump into our editor and we're going to go to our materials folder.
What I'll do is instead of going into the starter content, I'll just collapse that file
there.
I'll click on content and I'm going to right click new folder and I'll just create a folder
called materials here just to keep things organized.
You can put your materials folder wherever you'd like and then we want to right click
in the empty gray space here and we want to select material from the list here, the green
icon.
So good naming conventions are always useful to follow whenever you're working in projects.
For materials we like to use the M underscore naming convention and I'll just call this
M underscore base color and I'll hit enter on my keyboard and that will load this up.
So I'm going to get the base color and I'll show you again how to load that in case you've
not been able to load that but I'm just going to get this base color tab and pin that up
there.
Now if you had selected off it before hit and enter, you can just double click the file
as well and that will load as well.
So I've just pinned this to the top of my screen here.
I'm just going to go to file, save all just to make sure everything is always up to date.
Now the first thing we want to do is we want to add color to this material.
So I'm going to hold three on my keyboard and left click and that creates this node here.
I'm going to right click the node, I'm going to convert it to a parameter and I'm going
to spell color the British way here.
So apologies for anyone that I've spelt it wrong for and I'm going to drag out and go
into base color.
So I'm just going to get my left mouse button and drag across into base color.
I'm going to save again just to make sure everything's running okay and I want to select
a color for my color.
So let's go to the default value.
Again the details panel is where we're going to be editing a lot of our content.
So the default value I'm just going to select there on the black and I'm going to pick a
nice value.
Maybe that looks good.
So whatever color you'd like to pick, feel free to pick that and we will give our materials
From our workshop we'll give it a metal value and a roughness value just so we can affect
these at runtime.
So metal and roughness is where we're going.
So we'll press number one on the keyboard and left click to create these new nodes.
So before we clicked three and now we're going to click one.
So one into metal and then another one into roughness.
Now I want to right click again the node, convert it to a parameter and I call that
metal and I'm going to right click on this one, convert it to a parameter and call roughness
and you'll see why we're converting these to a parameter.
You'll see before we converted them they still had the same effect and everything would still
work without us converting them but as I save and I've got my basic color set up I'm
going to go into my third person map.
I'm going to navigate just using my left and right mouse buttons here.
I'm going to drag, get my color, drag and drop it onto here.
So you'll see that we've got a shiny material and that's because our metal value if I go
back to my color is zero and the roughness is zero.
And so if I close this now I don't need this editor anymore and I'm going to get this base
color, I'm going to right click on the base color so make sure you're on the base color.
I'm going to create a material instance and I'm just going to select off that.
Now what this has done is it's instanced this material so it's almost like a child.
If you think about this as a parent, this is a child.
I'm going to double click the child and I'm going to tick these three boxes here.
I'm going to tick metal, I'm going to tick roughness and I'm going to tick color.
And you'll see that these are the properties that we created parameters for.
So say for example we change the metal to one, it makes it way shinier.
So if I save this and close the material, you'll see that I've got a really shiny version
there and you can just keep creating.
Once you've got the base material set up, you'll see that I can just duplicate this
for example, double click it, maybe I change the color of this one, hit okay and save and
maybe I drag and drop that on the floor and you'll see now we've got this orangey color
that's reflecting from the sky.
Now this clearly looks awful and terrible.
I'm just trying to show you the intended result for what you can do with just basic functionality
and then you can edit the content based on those dynamic instances from the main material.
So that's just a quick example of how you might use the material editor inside of Unreal Engine.
So that's it for this video.
I hope you enjoyed it.
If you did, please like and subscribe.
I'll see you in the next one.
Bye.